welcome to this video 15 minute game
against ebrahim ebrahim mm-hmm okay from
Russia underwent d6 let's see Bobby
interesting yeah what idea of this move
our is to to go to to the Dutch in some
cases on try to make use that the night
is not yet on f6 here in fact there is
the move c5 Bishop g2 96 I think this
could be an idea and see after d5 there
is night to a 5 it's an interesting way
to play it's very similar to them
Yugoslav variation of them fianchetto
Kings Indian but I have not yet a knight
on f6 which modem prove interesting
let's see I'm not threatening to take on
c4 at the moment as of course there is
Queen a4 check however I can play a six
and try to prepare b5 here if right now
ignores all of it and place let's say 93
I'm going to take c4 ok so this be 50
move now or is it is it simply mistimed
be five checks interesting yeah it's
some very interesting um differences of
my bishop is so
g7 is opened compared to a normal banco
on comparable interesting b5 takes Queen
B 6 could be an idea b5 takes takes
Queen takes i dunno i can play Bishop d7
but oh wait there's actually see fall
and 93 winning the exchange of
interesting it could be it could be
quite good actually I don't think that
she has some has taken that into account
at all takes takes Queen takes Bishop d7
23 only move c4 tempo Queen moves and
not be three wins they exchange okay the
same has prevented so taking here I want
to take with the night to make sure that
or is there something else now I can
ever take maybe I have some way to avoid
the immediate capture some way to to
keep the tension
I wonder if he really threatens to to
take I don't think actually maybe I can
do that takes takes Knight ecstasy for
winning a piece so cannot we have now
and okay retreating a piece to try to
establish a night on see form okay the
open bishop is really nice he cannot
easily develop question is can i benefit
somehow
I wonder if what about night to h6 could
this be an idea getting in Knight to f5
hmm interesting okay I need to still
look at this capture takes takes Knight
eggs I still see forwarding a piece okay
takes takes Knight takes e4 still wins
apiece for me and then of course my idea
I need to UM complete the thought if he
goes efore here i can go Knight g4
intending 95 looks interesting maybe he
can be really tough about this and play
something like a for nigeria before
check King edge one night F to check
rook f to Bishop f2 Knight f3 it's
something like that trying to prove that
my pieces are completely off side it's
possible but what camp he needs to do
that first
and I don't necessarily need to UM Wow
well that's a weird move 95 I mean this
is of course is always a check here
that's clear I cannot play Knight f2 for
example but it's a 95 just just quite
pleasant for me yeah i think it is it
wins attempt can look we must take now
and at the end of all this i'm going to
take on c4 and simply have a good
positioner not sure maybe it's not
really a really important I mean the way
I actually take what I have in mind is
the complete trade down here are wait
wait a minute if I take with the pawn
maybe I should have considered this okay
yet you could have taken here I take
with the pawn Knight takes Queen to be
five has actually playable it's not
playable it's actually winning because
it's a deadly pin so yeah maybe maybe
Bishop d2 I can take be tuned there's
nothing that's not a move and I possibly
have rock b8 Queen a for this type of
stuff even see three actually so I'm
winning a pawn yes
and now Queen a forum is one one way to
do it
yeah this may be 52
yeah of course my night is still off
side there's no no way to deny that I
can play Queen 84 down I can really do
it Bishop g2 there is c3 I thought I
thought that hurt that Bishop d2 would
be a problem here attending you to take
and night see forward i have c 3
available which is very important
now he will not so easily get it back I
could have played c3 here and set off
queen 84 but I didn't like my night is
very exposed them I don't like it
likessee 3 takes Bishop takes Bishop t2
it didn't look right c3 it can be a good
option but it's a matter of timing ok
well here I can of course just take it
and I should take it but now if it if he
takes on b3 you to do the question is
what i should play now
okay probably all the way back but
that's just a clean pawn now on the
queenside oh really yeah that didn't
expect at all that he trades off my bed
night I mean his night on a three isn't
a good piece I know but he has nine AS c
2 e 3 ways to make it better which
wasn't so a self evident from my night
at least I couldn't really see it might
be seven okay over to d8 and then the
nitrate and then a night on 85 is always
a very tricky piece well known from the
chi Goran in the Rue La Paz which I
happened to play for a number of years
okay well this is just nice because it's
upon the a porn yeah he might play a 5
if I film i wonder if i should consider
to go bishop to deform activating it and
maybe playing f6 I just push the pawn
yeah probably push the pond here e 6 I
can relatively comfortably take takes
takes Queen c6 and I don't see a big
problem okay if I advance any further
might become tricky g5 is also possible
I wait here I can actually think about
playing Queen to f5 because the rock is
only one now
or ii 636 you are not sure e 6 looks a
bit a bit stupid a bit strange like like
after work T 1 for example it looks a
bit strange the smooth
okay if i push it I don't see why not
actually okay maybe the right moment I
need to take him look a six or should I
take it here getting the Queen to e5
and a move like rookie for counter
ticking I can go Quincy three yeah it's
not easy
you look a 1 he is going right into the
pin again yes I thought that Queen at
five might be with him
ok I'm done on time I need to play not
take ages for it ok it just takes it
there is rook be one now isn't this
winning material Jack I'm little late
spotting that but it's just winning
winning winning big big material takes
Queen texts with the check and then the
rook drops or King moves Andruw k 1 so
we couldn't really take on a three I
initially thought that Roque 3i will
take a five or take a three teky five
but this is of course just Adam and
that's a rook okay still if i take it
Queenie eight Bishop Bishop f8 this
Bishop to h6 that's sick
that's really sick
so how do I actually win now it's not so
clear to me maybeee five yeah if 5v5
looks good with the tempo on the bishop
that's important and if white takes
there is Queen takes and this the deep
hole I can I can think i can i can stop
stop relatively easily if you mostly
bishop there is just a bishop f8 and
i'll pick it up 26 next turn or let's
say d 727 creepers also pretty easy
i also have Bishop f6 to stop the deep
bone so this is pretty okay now I think
no big counter play whatsoever yeah not
we spending the time this is very always
very curious for me people play like a
15 minute game and here yet spent like
very little time and all those moves
very instantly very quickly and you
start to think in this position where
you totally busted like completely
busted okay so attacking of the c5 porn
um yeah I can I can play yeah Queenie
for is not so convincing actually a
Queen e4f 3 mmmm
it came home he wants to take on c5 him
there's some way to prevent it all
together I can give this check here
first f3 happy to be one this is not bad
going to be one that's threatening rook
a to Queen h1 and bishops Bishop c5
rookie to is easy ng7 I'm playing Bishop
f6 stopping the porn yeah okay I'll win
the Queen it's quite okay
white resides it has a very good
position right out of the opening I have
a wake vague memory that this is a quite
an interesting line for black tea 595 m
the question is how should white set up
on the queenside hell yeah castles now
we went queen bee three I don't know
maybe Creed III is not really it's not
clear that this is really achieving much
maybe you should think about 92 or 93
it's not clear to 23 I mean this is
quite nice I think interesting would
have been this which I'm Jack had seen
c3 Queen someone I'd be three which as I
SAT is winning the exchange but which is
sweet also totally unclear yeah this
might even good be good for white it's
got two points very nice position
actually um no I mean I don't need to
win they exchange it can also just play
this position and say I have a bank Oh
type of compensation but maybe you
should have tried that this is quite
nice yeah i can just recapture because
this is blundering yeah this is
debatable this night move i mean very
interesting to assess this position now
I i had to suggest that he ref for just
being completely cool about it this
Bishop before I Bishop a tree is just
bad i mean it's just the bad move this
is interesting
um check this is what I had check throw
out a bound then maybe something like
that tried to prove that this is a
stranded piece I don't think I would
have would have gone for that actually
I'm sorry computer also wants to take
here may be preparing it made preparing
it like this and now the check here the
census makes a much better check Russian
actually well it seems fine therefore is
interesting but ok played this rather
quickly and now after 95 Black is some
black is better only question is how
much better I get this nice play on the
queenside and even though porn here
interesting the computer just wants to
do this and now aged 5 h form castles
not sure that h5 is really anything
great but ok well this is this of course
ok for black I mean this is a good very
good diagonal and I have the bee farm I
just thought why not win this pawn oh ok
computer once play Queen to see to this
makes lots of sense actually try to get
this back
ya b3 is some just giving it away i
believe i can stop play this position
for sure it's not totally clear computer
wants to do this which I found really
surprising yeah probably this exchange
is not even so clear specialty to might
arrest the night this is what he played
Oh interesting that's just bad play I
mean I could have taken actually I
didn't really consider that but it's
it's possible I didn't want to get into
this kind of pin here this situation but
this is just completely winning for
black now that was bad I should have
reconsidered that much too quickly play
this move I just thought okay done that
did not not into the pendant and went
back and here White's position is still
very much playable well not after night
she forgot it was playable I thought he
would try to play against my night like
this for example and now yeah I don't
really have much else night to be seven
and then something like that and okay
well I'm upon up but a pawn does not
mean i'm winning immediately or easily
this is just just play alone for white
yeah now I mean I just this is really
just a pawn well just oh yeah here g5s
the computer move even more decisive but
this is also also winning right yeah it
is you have no way to to play that no
plate this and Group B one wins the
house and the problem is why does not
really have a move if he takes here just
grab it
check there is simply not enough
compensation can go here and I can start
to return things here because I've
already have an extra rook and a 20 will
win as well so I'm ya around here do
some it is already lost I mean this just
making it relatively easy but it was
already am already lost this is an
interesting move order only available
why are the modern type of move order
not why are the usual Kings Indian as
for the night stays on g8 for a long
while looks quite interesting from like
a brief ok I hope you enjoyed it maybe
you got some opening tricks out of it
thanks for watching